okay so today we're doing a key
programming for a
Dodge Durango
2020.
um
we're going to program a key with an
auto
you want to go to the passenger side
you want to go to this area and you just
put your hand here
and then you just pull it out
the first thing you see it's gonna be
this
which is going to be our star connector
we're going to take the ADC from Advent
diagnostic ADC 2011.
we're going to take that clip
and we're just gonna stick it
into that
area
just like that
as soon as we are connected
we're gonna put this in the OBD
hazard lights on
so ADC connected
to the OBD
OBD is connected
to the auto and then an extension cord
to give power from the OBD
and we're going to go to dodge
make sure the tool is connected to the
internet
and we're gonna go for manual selection
we're gonna go to North America
[Music]
we're gonna go to Durango
we're gonna go to 2020
I'm gonna go to smart key
yes
and then I hit okay
I'm just gonna hit okay
I'm gonna go to uh Imo's tattoo scan in
this case
then we're just gonna hit okay
after it does that you're just gonna go
and do add a key
and then you're gonna hit start
okay it's not going to erase any keys or
anything like that
so we have a password 2700
and we're gonna go into the learning
process so there is already four keys
and we're gonna hit yes
you can hold the key in our hand
and it's going to tell us to put it on
the center cancel
press and release the unlock button so
we're just gonna hold it here and it's
ready
according key number
five the learning is Success uh we do
one we do not want to do a next case
we're just gonna hit
no
um turn the flashers out
and job is done
and that same star connection location
will be the same on the Grand Cherokees